Welcome in, everyone.
We are inviting you to look through the lens of the classical Ismaili reading as we explore a really profound text.
We're looking at the treatise establishing the I Am Umate by Anay Saburi.
He now asks what the summit of creation actually authorizes and answers with his boldest claims about the Imam's dominion.
All was made for the Imam.
His spirit set his reach and the world's head must be its best.
That exact sentence, I mean, it captures A profound and honestly pretty uncomfortable crisis that we really have to unpack.
Yeah, it definitely does.
Because to establish where this whole conversation begins, we have to look at the massive, intricate ladder of creation the author has built.
He envisions this strictly ordered universe, you know, where absolutely nothing exists in isolation.
He asks you to look at the bare earth, just the base elements, and those elements rise and are refined into metals.
Like the earth yields gold, it yields silver.
It yields the unburnable ruby hidden deep down inside the rock.
But crucially, the rock doesn't actually know it holds a ruby.
Exactly.
And then the ladder moves up again.
The metals and the elements rise into plant life.
You get the balanced grain of the fields, the fruit-bearing trees.
But again, the tree has no idea it provides shade.
Yeah, there's no consciousness of its own utility.
Right.
I mean, exactly.
Then the plants rise into the animal kingdom.
The grazing herds, the beasts of burden, the predators.
And finally, the animals rise into humanity.
So 2 absolute conclusions sit locked together at the very top of that climb.
Which are.
Well, first, that humanity is the summit of the whole lower creation.
And 2nd, that the absolute summit of humanity is the I am.
Yeah.
And arriving at a summit is a really demanding thing.
How so?
Well, if you build an architecture of the universe that is just so
strictly hierarchical, so perfectly ordered from the lowest pebble all the way to the highest human soul, that positioning demands a resolution.
Because you can't just be at the top for no reason.
Exactly.
Being at the absolute pinnacle means everything beneath you either owes you something or you owe something to it.
The ladder of creation, as beautiful as it is, it leaves this massive question hanging in the air.
We can grant that the summit has been reached,
But what does standing on that summit actually authorize in practice?
What he's actually allowed to do.
Yes.
What may the leader do with the world below him?
What may he demand of it?
I mean, what does his position at the apex mean for you and for everyone else just standing on the rungs below?
And those questions demand that we look at the very foundation of ownership.
They really do.
Because we have to begin with this doctrine of dominion, which asks a rather accusatory question really, like,
Why was any of this made in the 1st place?
Yeah, why does the physical universe exist at all?
It's a massive question.
It is a sweeping question, but the author provides a really sweeping answer.
You know, look at the stars, the vast oceans, the metals buried in the dark.
Look at the grains swaying in the field, the massive herbs of animals.
The author has established that each lower rung exists purely for the sake of the rung standing just above it.
The lower creation serves the higher.
Exactly.
And now he closes the chain entirely.
The whole of natural creation was made for the sake of humanity.
Solely for humanity.
Yes.
The logic he relies on is that only a being who can possess conscious knowledge and derive conscious articulated benefit gives the rest of the natural world any point whatsoever.
Oh, I see.
Because think about it, a universe full of fruit that is never actually tasted or stars that are never navigated by or beasts that are never utilized.
The universe operating in a total.
Exactly.
It's pointless.
So without a human being to eat the fruit or mine the oar or ride the beast or even read the complex movements of the sky to measure time,
There would be 0 wisdom in a single plant or animal ever having been brought into existence.
None whatsoever.
They would just exist in an empty, purposeless loop.
They need a witness and they need a user just to give their existence a meaning.
Precisely.
But the chain doesn't stop at humanity.
It keeps going.
It does.
Humanity was not made for its own sake either.
Human beings were created for the imams.
Humanity exists to receive religion from them, to be perfected through them, and to manifest their order and foundation in the physical world.
So the worlds exist for humanity and humanity exists for them.
Yeah.
The entire point of everything in the cosmos is finally reached in him, because only in him does the ascent of creation complete itself.
And from that premise, a really startling consequence falls out.
It does.
If all the worlds were ultimately made for him, then all the benefit of those worlds belongs to him.
The rest of creation doesn't stand alongside him as an equal partner in some grand.
cosmic democracy.
Yeah, not at all.
It stands as children stand to a parent, entirely dependent, provided for, owing everything, and owed nothing in return by default.
So whatever is given back to creation is just a gift of generosity and mercy.
It's not a debt being repaid.
Which brings us to a stark, unsoftened reality that the author presents.
Consider the specific image of how an ordinary man looks at an animal.
This is crucial.
A man walks up to a beast.
He can decide on the spot what that animal's life is actually for.
He might decide to ride it to a distant destination.
He might milk it, he might shear it, or he might put it to really hard, exhausting labor in the fields.
Or eat it.
Exactly.
He might slaughter it for a feast, or he might simply let it graze peacefully in a meadow.
And he does
all of this entirely by his own judgment, completely against the animal's own inclination or instinct.
And absolutely no one calls that man a tyrant for doing so.
Because we just call it the natural order.
We do.
And the author builds his core assertion on this very picture.
He says humanity stands to the imam exactly as the animals stand to humanity.
I don't buy that yet everything belongs to the imam just sounds like a demand for property.
I get that.
Like it just sounds like a philosophical cover for absolute tyranny, you know?
Reducing human beings to livestock whose only purpose is to be used.
It absolutely sounds like sheer exploitation until you examine the underlying mechanics of that dominion.
What the author insists on is that dominion is inherently bound to a strict duty of care.
A duty of care.
Yes.
The mastery and the care are the exact same relationship.
Just read from two different sides.
Look again at the master and the animal.
Okay.
A wise master does not merely exploit his beast until it drops dead.
By the very norms of his rule, he is bound to protect it.
He has to keep it alive.
Exactly.
He guards its watering holes.
He secures its grazing grounds.
He shields it from predators in the night and tends to its well-being when it is sick.
Yeah, or else he loses the animal.
He even protects the animal against its own foolish appetites, you know, steering it away from poisonous plants it might try to eat.
Oh, I see.
The one who owns the flock is precisely the one obligated to keep it alive.
Mastery is not an exemption from duty, it is the heaviest duty there is.
So, the Dominion comes with a permanent, unbreakable charge attached to it.
isn't just the privilege to take, it's the obligation to sustain.
Yes.
The leader is bound by the norms of kingship, the demands of nature, sound policy, and sacred law to protect the welfare of mankind exactly as a man protects the welfare of the animals he governs.
And this duty of care is not some new invention the author just came up with.
It is the beating heart of how the tradition has always described just rule.
There's precedent for it.
Huge precedent.
Consider the instruction given by the commander of the faithful, peace be upon him, when he was dispatching a governor to Egypt.
What did he tell him?
He made mercy the absolute first charge of the office.
He commanded the governor, let your heart be filled with mercy for the subjects and love for them and kindness toward them.
Do not be a ravening beast over them, seizing what they have.
I mean, that's incredibly direct.
So the one set above the flock is bound to tend it.
Turning into a predator over the people is a betrayal of the office, not an exercise of it.
The higher the dominion, the heavier the duty of care bound to it.
If you are the summit, you carry the weight of everything below you.
Carry all of it.
But we still have to ask how this dominion is justified naturally.
Because the author doesn't just rest on theological claims, does he?
No, he doesn't.
He tries to ground this massive authority in the literal laws of biology and nature.
He does.
He returns to that ladder of nature we talked about, but this time he reads it specifically for what it says about power, capacity, and ruling.
Okay, let's break that down.
He asks you to observe how one rung actually rules the rung below it in biological terms.
Look at a plant.
Okay.
A plant surpasses the bare, lifeless earth
exactly one added thing, the spirit of growth.
Just so that one thing.
That single addition is enough to make the earth completely subservient.
The soil now feeds the root.
The ground becomes something the plant draws its strength from and uses to build its own structure.
That makes perfect sense.
Then you step up a rung, an animal surpasses the plant by one further spirit.
Which is.
The spirit of sensation, the power to feel pain, to desire, and to move voluntarily.
That one addition allows the animal to subdue the plant, walk over the ground, graze on the vegetation, and just consume it entirely at will.
And skipping up again, a human being surpasses the animal by one further spirit, reason, which the text calls N-O-O-T-Q.
This added spirit puts the entire lower world under human hands.
Man sows the earth, bends it to his wisdom, builds fences to corral the animals, rides them, slaughters them, and just uses them as he sees fit.
So at every single level of biology, possessing one added spirit is the entire difference between ruling and being ruled.
The one with the higher spirit always commands the one with the lower.
That is the universal pattern of existence.
And the author simply applies this ironclad biological law to the summit of humanity.
Okay, so what does that look like at the very top?
When the leader takes up his charge,
He is not left dwelling merely on the human rung.
He is endowed with further spirits, further powers, and a purity that no ordinary human being possesses.
Yeah, something extra.
A lot extra.
The choicest of the animal powers, the flawless balance of the elements, the finest influence of the celestial spheres, they all gather in him as the quintessence of the whole world.
Like A culmination.
Exactly.
Higher spirits unite in him, culminating in the perfect 7th creative spirit.
The spirit of oneness.
Oh, I see.
So if one single spirit reason was enough to make humanity the absolute master of the beast, the sheer weight of this array of higher, purer spirits establishes absolute dominion over humanity.
So rank isn't just a symbol.
Rank is not merely A symbolic title of authority here.
Rank is authority.
The literal number of spirits residing in the imams physically and naturally determines the extent of their control over humanity.
That is a profound shift in perspective.
Because that dominion is total, grounded in both care and biology, the author arrives at a very heavy conclusion regarding the taking of anything in this physical world.
It really does.
Because if all the benefit of the worlds ultimately belongs to the summit, whoever takes anything from this world without the permission and approval of the leader has committed a forbidden act.
It's not just a discourtesy or a minor infraction.
It's an act of literal usurpation.
It's a seizure of what is not yours to seize from an owner who never granted it to you in the 1st place.
Yes, and he anchors this directly in scripture.
He observes that whatever is bestowed on the messenger from the people of the villages is for God and the messenger.
But the focus there is on the word used for bestowal, isn't it?
The crucial focus is the specific word.
In the tradition, this is what they call FIE.
And what does that mean exactly?
Well, the root meaning of this term is not gift.
It is not spoils of war and it is not tax.
Its root meaning is return.
Return.
Yeah.
The author points out that Arabic uses this exact same word for a shadow.
A shadow is called this because in the evening as the sun sets,
The shadow comes back to the pace of the object from which it first stretched out.
Okay, I follow.
Everything in the world comes from the fortune and property of the imams in the 1st place.
So whatever passes into their hands is not being handed over to a stranger.
It is a return.
Like the shadow?
It is a shadow coming home at evening to the object that cast it.
That sounds like wordplay, calling every, taking a return so it can never count as theft.
It looks like an etymological technicality at first glance, I agree.
but it is actually doing massive structural work in the entire argument about the nature of property and rival claims.
Think about how property disputes work.
If the world were originally no ones, if it were just ownerless, neutral ground,
then the leader's claim on it would just be one claim among many.
You'd have to argue over it.
Right, exactly.
It would have to be weighed against the farmer's claim, the merchant's claim, the citizen's claim.
But if the world was his from the very start, if every good in it is essentially on loan from a source it is always naturally tending back toward, then no rival claim can even get started.
Because there's no neutral ground.
There is simply no unowned ground on which a rival could plant his flag.
The world does not become his property when he receives it
from you, it was always his.
So receiving it merely makes the ownership visible to us.
It just forces us to acknowledge what was already true in the architecture of the world.
Exactly.
You cannot usurp what is fundamentally unowned.
And once the author establishes that absolutely nothing here is unowned, taking without leave has only one name left.
Theft.
Taking an apple from a tree without acknowledging who the tree belongs to is a violation of the cosmic order.
This obligation to defer to the authority is written into the revealed command itself.
The scripture commands the believer to obey God, to obey the prophet, peace and blessings of Allah be upon him and his family, and in the very same breath, to obey those in authority among you.
And he interprets those in authority very specifically.
Yes.
The author reads, those in authority not as a loose reference to any politician or general holding power at a given moment, but specifically as the summit at the top of the ladder.
The world's benefit returning to its rightful owner and the believer's obedience flowing toward that same owner
are two faces of a single unified order.
But if we accept that the leader literally owns the world and that everything is a return to him, that puts a massive psychological burden on the believer.
It really does.
Like how is a person supposed to react when the leader issues a command they don't understand or does something that seems actively harmful?
That's the crisis.
This forces us to examine the posture the believer must adopt, which brings us to the doctrine of wisdom.
Yes.
The term for this specific posture is teslim.
It means a trusting submission.
It's a word that frequently causes modern sensibilities to recoil because it seems to demand an unquestioning blind obedience, you know, just the switching off of the brain.
Yeah, nobody likes feeling like they just have to shut up and obey.
Exactly.
The author knows this resistance is deeply natural.
Human beings want to understand what they are doing and why.
So he doesn't begin with a harsh command to simply shut up and obey.
He begins with an image of a farmer.
A farmer.
Picture a man of real agricultural insight walking over a vast tract of land.
He comes upon a stretch of good fertile soil and he knows instantly what its potential is.
He can see it'll grow things well.
Yes, he sees that it will take seed and give back immense growth.
But the land is dry.
So he looks around.
He locates water where others would never think to look, down in distant hidden valleys or buried deep underground beneath layers of rock.
Rather than shrugging and walking on because the task of bringing the water to the soil is incredibly difficult, he labors.
He digs complex canals, he sinks deep wells, and he carefully, meticulously directs that buried water to the wading ground.
Why does he go to such immense trouble though?
Because a man of genuine insight sees no wisdom in leaving good land idle.
He will not let good water remain sealed away in the dark.
It would be a waste and his deep abiding care for the world simply will not tolerate that waste.
I love that image.
The author transposes this exact image directly to the imams.
When they look at people, they do not just see subjects, they see fertile ground.
Oh, that's fascinating.
They see human souls ready, or nearly ready, to receive the seed of wisdom and knowledge.
Even if those specific people are still very far from being able to take it in plainly.
So they dig their canals.
Meaning they labor through preparatory religious exercises, through rigorous disciplines and complex rituals.
And the people subjected to these disciplines often cannot perceive their purpose at the time.
They wonder why they have to perform these specific actions at these specific times.
Of course they do.
But the leaders are patiently channeling toward the soul the water it will one day drink.
And where people simply cannot receive the raw, unvarnished wisdom plainly in open speech because it would overwhelm them or they would reject it entirely, the leaders do what a wise cultivator does with difficult ground.
Which is.
They embed the wisdom in dense symbols.
They place it in obscure words, allegories, and complex actions.
They do this so that people may take the symbol now, hold onto it, practice
and be raised by slow degrees to understand the profound meaning inside it years later.
The obscurity is not an act of withholding.
It is irrigation.
It is wisdom being carefully routed through a channel that the ground can actually absorb without washing away in a flood.
That image of the farmer is the absolute foundation for the submission demanded of the believer.
It becomes strictly necessary to believe in the supreme leadership, to know he is the head of the world and the channel through whom governance reaches creation.
It becomes
necessary never to object to any of his commands, prohibitions, actions, or teachings.
The believer must hold in advance before they understand anything, that all of it embodies absolute wisdom and is strictly for the welfare of creation.
Even when the particular point of a particular thing remains completely hidden for a very long while.
Even then.
The author is deeply realistic about how difficult this is, though.
He is.
The true meaning of a command might be genuinely hard to grasp, and a believer might feel intense internal resistance.
But he frames that resistance as a fact about the believer's limited sight, not a fact about the command's lack of wisdom.
That's the pivot.
He draws a direct parallel to the sacred law itself.
The faithful frequently do not understand what was intended in a certain ruling.
They might bristle at it initially.
They might find a prohibition deeply frustrating.
Yeah, very common.
Only later, when recognition is granted through study or lived experience,
Do they see the profound protective wisdom folded inside it the entire time?
The author is simply asking the believer to extend that exact same patience they already have for the static text of the law to the living guide of the law.
And it extends far beyond the law to the entire natural world too.
People constantly look at creation and see things they deem harmful dangers, pests, natural disasters, things in which they see absolutely no benefit at all.
They rush to conclude no good was ever in them, that the universe made a mistake.
Exactly.
Later, the broader ecological or scientific wisdom becomes visible, they grow calm, the objection falls away, and they cannot honestly deny the wisdom they now see.
The wisdom was not absent, it was just on a delay.
Yes.
Arriving long after the human complaint, you're being asked to grant that your present inability to see the point is merely a fact about the length of your own sight, not about the emptiness of the action itself.
And scripture provides a masterclass on this exact human limitation.
It certainly does.
It's the story of Moses failing this precise test when he set out to learn from his guide.
Yeah, very famous story.
The guide knew Moses' limitations and warned him at the outset that he wouldn't be able to bear what he was about to see, asking how he could have patience for that which he did not encompass in knowledge.
And Moses, despite his prophetic stature, could not maintain that patience.
He really couldn't.
The sequence of events is deeply uncomfortable, even horrifying from an earthly perspective.
Yeah, it's rough.
The guide scuttled a perfectly sound boat endangering the crew.
He killed a young man in cold blood.
He rebuilt a wall in a town that had just cruelly refused them hospitality and food.
And at each and every single act, Moses objected.
Because he couldn't see the reason.
He was entirely unable to hold his peace because all he saw was sheer, senseless damage.
It was only when the guide finally parted from him that the hidden wisdom was disclosed.
What were the reasons?
The boat was scuttled to render it defective and save it from being seized by a tyrant king who was taking every sound ship by force.
Oh, wow.
Oh, I mean, that is a wild twist.
Yeah.
And the young man was taken before he could grow up to commit atrocities and ruin his believing parents.
The wall was raised without payment to guard an orphan's buried treasure from the cruel townspeople until the orphan came of age.
So the wisdom had been there the entire time.
Moses did not lack his own wisdom.
He just lacked the patience to wait for the guide's wisdom to reveal itself.
Yes.
It's A jarring recognition that an act which looks like sheer, senseless damage from below may actually be a profound rescue when seen from above.
Exactly.
The distance between damage and rescue is only the length of one's own sight.
This narrative plea for patience then tightens into a rigorous, unforgiving theological proof.
It turns entirely on recognizing
God as the wise one.
Okay, lay out the proof for us.
If you truly grant that the wise one is wise, you have already granted something mathematically massive.
To call someone wise without qualification means everything they do is full of wisdom.
Right, I mean, yes, obviously.
Like they would never, ever do a single thing empty of it.
A futile act is simply impossible for such a being.
And the author is incredibly precise about defining what Fusal means here, isn't he?
Is.
A futile act is 1 where the doing of it and the not doing of it come to exactly the same thing, an act you could have skipped with nothing lost either way.
That kind of arbitrary action is impossible for the wise one because it would mean wisdom would sit in idle and a wisdom that idles
contradicts the very name.
Now watch the hinge of the argument carefully.
Okay.
If it is mathematically impossible for the wise one to perform even one act whose presence and absence are equivalent, how could the leader perform an act where the wisdom lay somewhere else or in the very opposite of what he did?
He couldn't.
He cannot.
His wisdom is not his own personal hard-won human achievement.
It is a direct bestowal.
To act at random without wisdom is to act corruptly and in vain.
The office inherently forbids this.
Which makes the final step of this doctrine incredibly severe.
It does.
To believe that the leader of the time has acted without wisdom is not just a small localized error of judgment about one specific political decision.
No, it's much bigger than that.
It is to declare that this individual has fundamentally departed from wisdom entirely.
And whoever has departed from wisdom has by that very fact departed from the domain of his office.
The office simply is the seat of wisdom in the world.
A wisdomless leader is a literal contradiction in terms.
To depart from that domain is to depart from the faith itself, since the faith is entirely built upon that seat.
That's a huge claim.
It is, an objection that feels like ordinary healthy criticism saying this command makes no sense.
Turns out, when followed to its dimest root, to be a complete denial of the whole structure the believer claims to stand inside.
The author presses this through the images of severe guides, doesn't he?
Yeah, he uses a few.
Like the teacher who drives students through deeply resented, exhausting lessons, knowing they will thank him when they mature, or the physician who forces bitter medicine or even lancing and cauterization on a patient who cannot yet see that the agonizing pain is actually the cure.
The severity is a difficult mercy, cutting only to heal.
A wise agent cannot act pointlessly.
There is no such thing as an act that is truly empty, no matter how void it appears from your vantage point below.
The submission demanded is not a surrender of the mind.
It is what the mind necessarily concludes once it is actually granted that the wise one is genuinely wise.
All was made for the imam, his spirit set his reach, and the world's head must be its best.
Moving from the theology of the wise one to the sheer mechanics of the world forces us to ask another fundamental question.
Okay, what's that?
We have leaned heavily on scripture and faith so far, but what if we strip all of that away?
Just use reason.
Exactly.
The author now pivots to make his final claim using reason alone.
With 0 scripture required, he argues that the world must have a single supreme leader and that this leader must be the absolute best of all who live.
This brings us to the stakes of the office.
He proves the necessity of a single head using a progression of distinct pictures and proves the necessity of it being the best using a strict linguistic point.
Start with the pictures.
We begin with the most accessible picture of human dependency, the shepherd and his flock.
Okay, paint the picture.
Imagine a massive flock of livestock grazing freely on open ground.
These animals have real inherent worth.
They provide wool, milk, meat.
There's nothing biologically defective about them as animals.
Yet left entirely to themselves, they perish.
Because they can't choose their own pasture wisely.
Right, I mean exactly.
They overgraze and destroy the root systems.
They cannot find their own water consistently in a drought.
They cannot organize a defense to fend off the thief or the predator.
They can't manage their own long-term survival.
What they lack is not strength or value.
They lack a shepherd.
They need
someone with a broader view to select the grazing, guard the watering places, and stand between them and whatever seeks to kill them in the night.
People, the author argues, are exactly like this.
Despite all human gifts, despite our intellect and our cities, without a shepherd to protect our worldly and religious lives,
We would.
We'd be devoured by our own ambitions, scattered by our disputes, unable to secure our own ultimate good.
And if he is the true shepherd, then everyone else claiming that roll over the flock is not a rival shepherd, but a wolf.
A predator really dressed as a protector.
Actively thinning the flock, it pretends to guard.
The author points to the ordinary word for subjects to seal this.
People everywhere in their everyday language are called Rai-i-ya.
And that word has a literal meaning, doesn't it?
Does.
That word literally means a flock under a shepherd's care.
So the very language society uses to describe itself confesses that it inherently expects and requires to be shepherded.
Yes.
The only question the word leaves open is who the true shepherd is and who the wolves are.
This relies on a profound law of responsibility articulated by the Prophet, peace and blessings of Allah be upon him and his family.
That's right.
He stated that each of you is a shepherd and each of you is responsible for his flock.
It runs imamate all the way down the social structure.
the ruler over his people, the man over his household, woman over her home.
Shepherding is not just one specialized office among many.
It is the fundamental shape of all human responsibility.
It is.
If the head of a single household stands as a shepherd, the head of the whole human community must stand as the shepherd of shepherds, the one on whom every lesser flock ultimately depends.
From the shepherd, the author moves to a second picture to raise the physical stakes of this necessity.
What's the second picture?
He moves from the flock perishing slowly over time to the body collapsing immediately.
Oh, this one is vivid.
He asks you to picture a headless body.
A body without a head is not an injured body.
It is not a body with a broken arm that can heal.
No, it's a decaying corpse.
It is of absolutely no use to anyone.
He applies this directly to the world.
A world with no head, no leader, no steersman or SAA is to steer its affairs would not just limp along in disorder, it would rot.
People would turn into beasts, devouring one another.
Yeah, chaos.
The author insists the world would not endure even a single day.
It's deliberately extreme.
Is.
It crushes a very tempting middle position.
The idea that leadership is nice to have, but a society could stumble on without it in a pinch, maybe governing itself through committee or consensus.
The author says no.
Headship is to the world what the head is to the biological body.
A body can survive the loss of many limbs, but it cannot survive the loss of the head.
What remains is not a wounded order, but a carcass.
And to close off the final escape route, the modern suspicion that leadership is just a human convention we invented and could simply uninvent if we chose to, he provides a third picture.
The ranks of nature.
Exactly.
Look at the natural world around you.
Headship is built into it everywhere, long before any human being ever formed a society.
The stallion guards and disciplines the mares.
The rooster watches over the hens.
Every species defends its females and young.
guiding the weak among its own kind based on an innate hierarchy.
The crane obeys its leader in flight, forming that perfect V-shape to cut through the wind.
Yeah, or the bee.
The bee obeys its queen, organizing an incredibly complex society in the hive.
The author points out that creation is arranged on a strict pattern of gradation and rank, making it unmistakable that within every single species there is a peak, a summit, a chief in nobility and worth.
By that exact same rational observation, mankind must
likewise have a peak and a summit in nobility and worth to serve as a guide.
Hitship is a deeply embedded feature of nature, instinct, and intuition.
Yes.
Even those who deny revelation entirely cannot deny by pure reason or observation that the world absolutely requires leadership.
They can't escape it.
He uses the shepherd to prove competence isn't the issue.
The flock isn't defective, just unshepherded.
He uses the body to prove leadership isn't a slow acting good.
Without it.
Society rots in a day.
He uses nature to prove it isn't a human invention.
The stallion and the crane never debated governance.
Every exit is closed.
The world must have a single head.
Even if I can see that we absolutely need a leader to avoid rotting in a day, why must it be an absolutely perfect supreme summit?
Can't society survive with just a good enough ruler?
A compromise candidate?
Yeah, someone who makes mistakes but keeps the roads paved.
This is where the argument executes its tightest and most fascinating turn.
Having established the world must have a supreme leader, he proves that this leader must be the absolute best of all people.
The most noble, perfect, and knowledgeable.
Yes, and he does it using a pure point of grammar.
The plain sense of the words dictates reality.
So basically calling a follower a supreme leader isn't just bad politics, it's a literal grammatical typo.
It's an oxymoron.
The title of supreme leader simply cannot be laid upon the one who is himself led.
The words mean opposite things.
Precisely.
The title of the excellent cannot be laid on the one who is surpassed by another, the one they call math duel.
The title of the one who precedes cannot be laid on the one who is preceded.
The mass boo cue.
call the lead man the leader or the surpassed man the excellent is not merely A moral failing or a political compromise.
It is a literal linguistic contradiction.
It is applying a word to its own contrary.
Supremacy is not an extra honor we politely attach to the leader after the fact like a medal.
It is contained in the very idea of the leader, just as being surpassed is contained in the idea of the surpassed.
The author claims universal agreement on this principle.
Philosophers, deniers of God, people of every community,
leader of the world ought to be the best, most perfect, and most knowledgeable.
On the principle itself, everyone agrees.
We all want the doctor who is the best at medicine, the pilot who is the best at flying.
And that grammatical, universally accepted principle is the unshakable ground on which he lands the entire argument.
It is.
In all the world, no one fits this exact description, most knowing, most pure, most complete, except the Amoms.
Yes.
Scripture had already exposed this as a subtle point regarding the plain sense of
what a guide is, asking whether he who guides to the truth is more worthy to be followed or he who cannot guide unless he himself is guided?
Exactly.
To follow the guided in place of the guide is a profound failure of judgment about the very definition of the word.
I have to concede the interlocking logic here.
This is where the pretenders completely fall out of the running based on their own fundamental qualifications.
They do.
The author leans on the philosopher's 3 governances.
governing oneself, governing one's household, governing the public.
There's A strict, unbreakable chain binding them.
Yes, you can't skip a step.
No one who cannot rule his own soul has any business ruling a family and no one who cannot rule a family has any claim to ruling a people.
The pretenders who have seized titles throughout history cannot even govern their own appetites.
They are given over to depravity, greed and corruption.
Because they cannot govern their own base desires, they fail the absolute lowest rung of governance.
They fail step one.
The field of candidates isn't crowded with viable options.
It is entirely empty of everyone but the Imam.
ownership, trust, and inevitability lock together.
Which brings us to the profound practical reality of what this chapter establishes.
We have covered the biological dominion, the absolute wisdom, and the rational necessity of the best.
Yeah, we've covered a lot of ground.
It might feel like we have been discussing authority in the abstract, you know, floating in a realm of pure philosophy.
A bit, yeah.
But the author presses hardest on the fact that this authority is not floating free of daily life.
It is enacted concretely in every single
pillar of the religion.
The daily prayer, the annual fast, the giving of alms, not one of them stands or even means what it means without the central presence of this leadership.
The sacred lot is not a self-running machine that the leader merely presides over from a distance, like a clockmaker watching a clock.
No, it's not.
It is a living body, drawing its life directly from its head.
The dominion?
The wisdom and the necessity are not just doctrines to grant intellectually and then set aside.
They are the living hinge on which each act of daily worship turns.
The submission we discussed earlier is not the surrender of the mind, but the mind's ultimate conclusion once it accepts that the wise one is truly wise.
All was made for the imam, his spirit set his reach, and the world's head must be its best.
Where do you resist a wisdom only because you cannot yet see its point?
And what would waiting on it cost you this week?